the US is pulling out of a nuclear
missile pact with Russia the
intermediate-range nuclear forces treaty
has been in place for more than 30 years
president Trump accused Moscow of
violating the deal Russia has violated
the agreement
they've been violating it for many years
and I don't know why President Obama
didn't negotiate for pullout and we're
not going to let them violate a nuclear
agreement and go out and do weapons and
we're not allowed to we're the ones that
have stayed in the agreement and we've
honored the agreement but Russia has not
unfortunately founded the agreement so
we're going to terminate the agreement
we're going to pull out unless Russia
comes to us and China comes to us and
they all come to us and they say let's
really get smart and let's none of us
develop those weapons but if Russia is
doing it and if China is doing it and
we're adhering to the agreement that's
unacceptable
so we have a tremendous amount of money
to play with or our military the treaty
has been in force since 1987 under the
pact Russia and the u.s. required to
eliminate nuclear missiles with a range
of 1,000 to 5,500 kilometers but the
deal does not include C launched
missiles it was seen as a key milestone
in ending the Cold War Russia has
repeatedly said it will keep observing
the INF treaty as long as the US does
however Russian President Vladimir Putin
said last year that if Washington were
to renounce its obligations Moscow would
do the same this is the unity of God
usually if our American partners exit
the agreement we will give an immediate
and reciprocal response we've complied
with the agreement and we will continue
to do so as long as our partners do the
same we're joined now by Michel Maloof
former Pentagon security official thanks
Michael for coming on to the program now
the INF treaty it was an important step
wasn't it in ending the Cold War arms
race and now after more than 30 years
the u.s. is pulling out how significant
is this well I think it's significant in
that for a number of reasons number one
it has
it has held the peace if you will and
particularly you know between Russia and
the United States and and Europe in fact
for that length of time I think that
there's more ulterior motives attached
to all this the if you listened closely
that has never been mentioned what the
violations have been alleged violations
have been by Moscow number two there's
only been one meeting between the United
States and Russia since last for over a
number of years in fact and never once
has there been any talk of sitting down
and discussing alleged violations and
trying to recommit to adherence on both
sides but number three there's something
more significant to this Unitas and
Trump just raised that in his comments
the United States would rather pull out
because of China right now it cannot it
does not it cannot develop new
intermediate-range missiles to to
confront China even though China is not
a signatory to that agreement so this is
this is adding a whole new ball of wax
that even though even though China was
not a signatory to that to that
agreement the United States feels that
it's now at a disadvantage in the
development of intermediate range of
missiles and I would add one last caveat
to all this it was Bolton John Bolton
his national security adviser who really
pushed Trump to this decision and and
Bolton has been in the forefront getting
the United States to act unilaterally
not only in this in this case but also
in dropping out of the the Iranian
nuclear agreement and and and putting
troops into Syria toward the idea of
regime change so bold is a very
dangerous fellow
and Trump is not really in charge of his
own foreign policy I mean if we look at
the finger-pointing that's going on
Michael Trump saying Russia has been
violating the treaty and Moscow has
repeatedly accused the u.s. of failing
to meet its obligations
but do we know who is really to blame
and like you mentioned before we don't
know what those violations are meant to
be do we know and and if they were
really serious about trying to correct a
problem if in fact there was one they
would have sat down and talked but it's
Bolton does not want to deal with Russia
even though he's going to be going to
Moscow I believe next week and he's
going to inform foreign minister Lavrov
that there the u.s. is pulling out now
is this is this a basis for them now to
negotiate a better deal as the trumpet
Trump always calls for that's a
possibility but I think the overriding
concern right now is China and because
there isn't that China is not a
signatory to that arrangement yeah I
mean we saw that didn't we in in the
clip of Donald Trump speaking talking
about that new deal that you've
mentioned as well yes how likely is it
that that new deal will indeed be
negotiated between Russia between China
between the u.s. well let's see what
happens as a result of the meetings I
don't think they it's a six-month notice
so anything can happen there's going to
be a meeting of Trump with Putin at the
g20 within the next month that might be
an opportunity for them to sit down and
seriously discuss this thing and put off
any precipitous action that he just
announced again I think he's he's trying
to leverage Russia and we'll just see
what happens and but there is six months
it has to be a say it is a six month
notice and if he lays it down formally
when he went when in Bolton then lays
that down formally when he goes to
Moscow that's when the clock begins as
you've mentioned Mike Michael pulling
out a treaty seems to be an ongoing
theme for Trump he feels he feels that
they're just not operating from a
position of strength and it's America
first
all the usual rhetoric that
cheering and again China is the key on
this and and and Bolton is of the
mindset that were at a disadvantage and
he's convinced Trump that that we need
to do something and I might add that
even defense secretary mattis is
expressed concerns about alleged
violations but again nobody knows what
those violations are is it the person is
it the idea of developing a new cruise
missile well the treaty doesn't prohibit
that and the United States is developing
new intermediate missiles and cruise
missiles but again they can they can
develop them they can research they just
can't deploy okay we'll leave it there
for now
Michael Miley former Pentagon security
official thanks very much for coming on
to the program
you